in this problem a given pumping well
fully penetrates an unconfined aquafer
which sits above an impermeable layer
beneath it the impermeable layer is 150
ft below the surface of the ground the
well is 18 in in diameter and the
average permeability of the aquafer soil
is 175 ft per day an observation well
800 ft away assists in determining that
the flow rate out of the pumping well is
2,2 50 Gall per minute by measuring the
depth of water there at 25 ft below the
ground surface assume that the ground
surface at each well is the same what is
the height of the water above the bottom
of the aquafer at the pumping well in
feet so this is a really long problem to
read out and it contains pretty much all
of the information that we need we just
need to know how to put it together so
the first thing to note is that this is
an unconfined aquafer Pages 425 and 426
of the reference manual have information
about unconfined aquifers with respect
to Wells and groundwater flow so we can
find it just by searching well in the
reference manual specifically the
equation we will use to solve this
problem is given as dep
formula I have already also drawn out
the graphic included in the reference
manual on these pages so that I can more
easily show you what each term in the
equation actually
represents so let's start filling in our
known and see what we have to solve for
so we have dep's formula here and we can
see what information we've been given
throughout the problem so Q has been
given
as
2250 gallons per
[Music]
minute k is going to be our hydraulic
conductivity and that's been given at
175 feet per day
H1 is the height of the water above the
bottom at the pump well
[Music]
perimeter
H2 is the height of the water above the
bottom at the observation
well
R1 is the radius of the pumping
well and R2 is the radius from the
pumping well to the observation
well so let's start filling in our
G height one is what we're going to be
looking for since that is the height of
the water above the aquifer above the
bottom of the aquifer at the pumping
well so we don't have this value
yet height two is going to be given
as the difference between the depth
below the surface of the
ground so this entire length
minus the
depth of the water below the ground
surface at the observation
well equals
150 ft minus 25 ft
equals 125
[Music]
ft the pump well radius we've we already
know because we've been given the
diameter in inches up here so that's
going to be
0.75
ft
and R2 is going to be 800 feet away from
is the observation well distance away
from the pumping well so that's just 800
ft so we can see that we have all of our
terms we we have K we
have H2 we have R2 and R1 the only thing
we're missing is H1 and we have q like
we mentioned so we just need
to change the units in Q so they they
match those of
K and we can just proceed to solve the
problem so Q is gallons per minute we
want to convert this to feet per day so
or cubic feet per day
multiplying all that out we get 4 3
55 cubic
feet per
day and now we can set up the rest of
the equation
so rewriting D formula over here with
our known in it we can say 4 3 3 1
55 fet cubed per
day equal Pi * K is
175 feet per
day times H2 is 125 ft so
125t squared minus H1
squar over
Ln H R2 we mentioned was 800 ft and R1
is 0.75 so 800 ft over 0.75
ft and now all we have to do is simplify
this down if we start by multiplying the
quantity of Ln here over to the other
side of the equation and then simply
dividing out our PI and our K we get 5 4
96t squared equals
fet squared minus H1
SAR rearranging this we can say H1 squar
equal 125 ft^ squared minus
5496 ft^
squar
and squaring this doing the subtraction
simplifying down for H one gives
us
10064 ft which we can see over here is
our second answer on the list and that's
all it takes to solve this problem so
the most important thing in this
particular question is understanding
that this is an unconfined aquafer and
then recognizing what your H1
H2 R1 and R2 values
are and also under understanding how to
solve for what your H1 and H2 are
supposed to be in this case you only had
to solve for H2 by subtracting the total
depth or rather by subtracting the depth
of the observation well from the ground
surface from the total depth of the
entire aquafer and that's it